la polémique sur le manque de masques
continue de grandir en france avec les
moyens du bord de plus en plus
d'initiatives se met en place aux quatre
coins du pays
dernière en date à saint-andré-lez-lille
dole nord avec l'entreprise lemahieu
spécialisée dans la confection de sous
vêtements cette société va désormais
produire des masques des employés qui
étaient au chômage partiel depuis le 16
mars sont revenus travailler sur la base
du volontariat
chaque jour il devrait produire près de
3000 masques homologué par le centre
hospitalier universitaire de lille et
les fournir à l'établissement après
couteau que c'est pas bénévole puisqu'on
est une entreprise donc ces personnes
vont travailler
par contre on va vendre le projet au
prix coûtant dans le système en fait on
va juste facturé à prix coûtant la
préparation des matières la découpe le
contrôle qualité n'envoie et puis après
pour certaines couturière qui sont ici
encore une fois sur la base de
du volontariat ben voilà on va facturer
un prix de masques qui sera fabriquée
chez le maillot ou sinon le fabriquer à
l'extérieur pour un prix qui va être le
dérisoire finalement cet élan de
solidarité a créé une chaîne de
bénévoles vient le site internet souffle
du nord dix mille couturiers et
couturières de la région ont proposé
leur aide
l'entreprise fait parvenir des kits de
50 masques à coudre directement chez eux
quand ils ont envoyé par boîte qui sont
là bas dans les cartons
c'est acquis tant fait complet en fait
trop mais 50 on met les élastiques ou en
fait les personnes en prison qui les
attend car après ça on voit directement
chu par 50 dans les collures solaris
afghan va couvrir à 50
ces masques reviennent ensuite dans
l'entreprise pour passer le test qualité
une initiative précieuse pendant cette
période de pénurie inquiets face aux
risques encourus par ses équipes
frédéric boiron directeur général du chu
de lille après si cette mobilisation
solidaire
je le fais par choix parce que je crois
à des valeurs et je crois que c'était un
bon modèle qui est très précieux dans
notre pays on est un des rares pays
développés à avoir un tel système
d'hospitalisation public et je vois là
ici ces gens ces entreprises ces
associations qui se mobilisent
finalement leur demande est aussitôt ils
se mobilisent et nous aident et c'est
pas pour faire de l'argent c'est pour
être solidaire voilà qu'est ce qu'il ya
de plus beau dans notre société
franchement il n'y aurait pas d'hôpital
public serré pas de solidarité
ces masques sont destinées à tous les
personnels hospitaliers
or gestes de soins et ne remplace donc
pas les masques en papier jetables mais
il représente une option salutaire face
à la pandémie qui sévit en france